[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show where america hangs
out to have a money
to have a conversation about your life
and your money
my name is anthony o'neill host of the
popular youtube
and podcast show the table with anthony
o'neil and co-hosting with me today
is a national best-selling author and
host of the dr
john delony show and together we're
taking your phone calls today triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five
five two two five any questions around
money
any questions around relationships any
questions around
your mental health uh give us a call and
uh
single brothers any questions with you
all wondering can you purchase a home
as a single man give us a call uh
right here live on the air because you
know today you have two single men in
here we can answer that question uh i
got attacked yesterday for
i'm not single i mean i'm cinco you said
you got two single men in here but
you're the coach though you're the
mental coach so you can help out single
brothers too
oh so if one of them calls yes yes yes
christy got me in trouble yesterday
because uh
oh i like how you did that typical
single guy blaming
the powerful strong brilliant woman
continue go ahead man
she got you in trouble i like how you
started that off oh no no no no
i'm just saying so i'm just saying
though it's gonna be a good day all
right it'll be good it's gonna be a real
good day
uh man i mean it is jam-packed um out
there in the lobby today hey you guys
man looks amazing everybody some
good-looking people out there chilling
with us
um you know what they came today because
they heard dave was out and they heard
you and i were taking over the show
that's i and so um you know yeah she
look at him saying yep
yep and so you know you got a little bit
of chocolate and vanilla yes
lord triple eight eight two five five
two two five
is uh the number give us a call madison
is standing by and she would definitely
pat you through let's go ahead and jump
on the phone lines man you ready for
let's do it
um let's talk to rachel out in new york
good afternoon rachel
uh this is anthony o'neil how can dr
john and i help
hey guys i am good and so then um yeah
thank you so much for taking my quote
yeah thank you for calling in yeah so my
question is right now um my husband and
i are currently on baby step two
and we've paid off um like 58 000
uh which is a way which has been great
and we've been um
yeah like following this step but right
now we have
22 000 left and it i don't know we're
just
like struggling to find motivation i'm
um i'm in grad school
and then my husband is working right now
in sales and it's
i don't know we're just we're struggling
to balance between even
continuing to um you know have developed
intensity
and then also balancing life and
um and it's also tough because like no
one else i don't know like our friends
and family
don't um do this ramsay and so it's kind
of
um it's not just kind of lonely i mean
obviously we have the two of us to like
support
each other but it's i don't know yeah
it's just lacking motivation
i guess so you said you're 58 in
you got 22 to go yep oh you're so close
man yeah man
what are you going to grad school for
what are you going to grad school for
chemistry chemist oh chemistry yeah
it's so cool to talk to smart people
anthony it's like one of my favorite
things i know
especially people smarter than me yes
but you know let's celebrate rachel the
fact that you paid off 58
000 all right one of the key things that
you have to do when it comes to
uh keep pushing through the baby steps
is is acknowledge
okay where did you start where are you
at today and
celebrate those wins and so you are
paying off 50 you paid off 58 000
this is great this is amazing like i'm
i'm ready to put you on the stage and
say this have a future debt free screen
yes okay
because you've done what most people are
not
willing to do they're not to eat let's
go i'm just saying
i'm excited for it i'm super excited why
are you rachel why are y'all getting out
of debt what's
why yeah so i like the biggest thing for
us
is um just with like i don't know like
our legacy and our family
um like we both have great families um
right and they're awesome but even just
kind of like continuing that godly
heritage we have
but we also want to continue the godly
heritage
and not have like any financial issues
you know because i even think like one
of the things um
even with uh it is cool because it's
something
you know it's almost like spiritual
formation like wealth building um
and it's nice like to not have any of
the financial distractions and be able
to
you know the only reason we tell people
um no
isn't because we don't have the finances
to do it it's just you're choosing not
because we don't want to yeah so when
you say you're struggling with staying
motivated
paint me a picture of that is it just
you wake up and it feels crummy or you
just have days when you're like this
just sucks
or you're in a season now where
you've been doing grad school and
chemistry mostly online and it's
exhausting and your husband's been on
the road
and it's exhausting and then it's still
march something and we're just coming
out of
the cold season and it's exhausting and
everything just kind of is like
yeah i think um the biggest thing for us
that's hard is
so kind of what you're saying right
where it's like um uh
you know we're doing stuff with our
careers and we're kind of like the
beginning training stages
um and i think it's hard because it's
it's almost like we sometimes just feel
kind of um
lonely i guess pursuing um
yeah like uh like um a wealthy lifestyle
i guess for lack of a better word
or doing things that are really weird
like usually i don't know most of the
time but sometimes
it's like oh man this is just great and
like i know the why
it's so hard when you like you don't
have the strong community
around you of people who are also doing
it um
i don't know because it's like i guess
again as i said we have each other but
it's just sometimes it's like
i wish we had more people yeah well
rachel rachel a lot of
a lot of my millionaire friends told me
this and i want to give this pass this
down to you because i think
one of the things that i teach within um
my particular tribe is if your why
doesn't make you cry then the price of
commitment
will make you cry and so i hear you say
you're why but i i want to hear you get
a little emotional about your why
and i think if you can get a little
emotional if your why is so deep that
sometimes it brings tears
to your eyes your father's i mean your
husband's eyes
then you can push through but i also
want to encourage you and just remind
you this is not a popular statement but
sometimes when you are
going and doing things that normal
people do not do
you will feel lonely every time you will
you know and so it's like for me
on this journey that i have right now of
not racking up any debt of building a
legacy for my kids
you know i do feel a little lonely but
you know what i understand that it's
okay
because where i'm going is going to be
for the best for me and my family
and i refuse to be comfortable and broke
i'd rather be uncomfortable a little
lonely and wealthy
okay and so um my suggestion to you is
identify that why spend some time and
just get deeper in that wide until you
start feeling some
eyes coming not some eyes some tears
coming out of your eyes
then from there just remind yourself hey
we're going to be a little lonely
and that's okay and everyone who feels
lonely when they're doing something
weird
for the betterment of themselves their
family their community
i promise you there's a group of weirdos
in your local community if you will
if you will go first you cannot do this
alone that's why we have the
baby steps communities online and in
person you gotta reach out and find some
people get a y
yeah that will get stuck in your throat
and then go find people that are gonna
wrap themselves around you man
they are out there go do the work and
find people absolutely if your why
doesn't make you cry
then the price of commitment the price
to true success
will make you cry we're gonna talk more
about this right here
on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know health care has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had
chm chm saved our life shame brought to
my financial lives
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but it is a budget friendly option and
the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neil ramsey personality
joined in the studio with me
is also a national bestselling author
and host of the
doctor john delaney show the one and
only dr john delonia we're taking your
phone calls this hour triple eight eight
two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five
two two five and america i want to say
if you're ever in the area
an air in the city uh if you're ever in
the city of nashville
or franklin uh murfreesboro and you just
want to come
come out and just chill uh come by the
office
tour our office tour the lobby um and
have some cookies i'm telling you right
now you see them waving at you some
people are inviting you to the beautiful
city of franklin tennessee
um and i'm telling you right now the
cookies smell good as soon as you walk
through the door
you're going to want to stay here for
about a good two three hours and enjoy
uh listening to dave and one of the
personalities on the ramsay show
and they're pushers over there man are
they they will figure out how to get
those cookies
yes man get into your body it's the
chocolate chip
man you know i'm an oatmeal raisin guy
but man i'll tell you what
they make them there every day i'm gonna
talk i'm gonna talk to dave and our
producer james and see if
we're allowed to eat one of the cookies
while we're on the show on the show
that'd be so cool
oh man let's go out to the phone lines
again triple eight eight two five five
two two five you know we're talking
about your life so any area you want to
talk about give us a call
and uh we'll walk you through and give
you our opinions our our wisdom and
knowledge and if we can't answer the
question believe it or not
america we will say i don't know i'm not
going to say that but well i will i'll
say that because uh you know i don't
want to get sued
let's go out to oklahoma have a
conversation with ruby
good afternoon ruby how can dr john and
i help
i'm trying to figure out if i should
start saving for a house now or make
double payments on my debt
okay all right talk to us uh give us a
bit more information about yourself how
much debt are you in
uh currently i have about twenty four
hundred dollars left out of twelve
thousand dollars for my divorce
okay so you you're only at twenty four
hundred dollars left in in debt and you
paid off
well that's out of twelve thousand
dollars okay cool what's your household
income
uh my household income about every two
weeks is just a little over nine hundred
dollars
also eighteen hundred dollars a month is
your net
yes okay and that also includes the 401k
which i put five percent in
and my employer matches that five
percent okay cool
and uh you have any kids ruby
i have two okay two kids and i don't
receive child support or any financial
help
any reason why you don't receive child
support
yeah i expect that child support about
the same time i'll get half of the
mutual debt paid back so never so
pretty pretty yeah okay all right okay
that's i hate that for you ruby is i
know
with my tax bracket i will re starting
in june i'll be getting that extra 500
a month okay for the next month okay
all right all right well ruby what's
this 2400 in debt i'm curious
uh it was just for my divorce um i was
getting my excessive money orders to pay
like the taxes
on our land and on the state taxes and
stuff like that and apparently he never
paid him okay
so i had to take out uh to loans to
consolidate
everything because there was tobacco
taxes
and i got most of that paid off i think
i have 800
left on that loan and then
my other ones are i have a senior hud
account which is what i've done
christmas with for the last few years
okay
uh that was probably my highest one that
one right there is
i think around fourteen hundred dollars
okay all right and then the rest of the
kids a little bit on credit cards that i
use before gas and then i pay back
use for gas and payback so it's
revolving credit okay cool
all right sounds good i mean well it
doesn't sound good at you ain't dead but
i mean
you don't it doesn't sound too bad um so
to answer your question i'm going to
give you
a one part question then i'm gonna give
you some extra stuff that you didn't ask
for
number one is no ma'am you're not in a
position to purchase a home just yet all
right
i'm not saying that you will not be uh
but as of right now
with twenty four hundred dollars in debt
and only making eighteen hundred dollars
a month as in your net
which i'm guessing you're right around
twenty four hundred dollars gross
um right now we need to focus on just
creating a solid foundation for you and
your kids
so i'm gonna say double up on your debt
do you have any money in your savings
account right now
no i've been putting everything towards
paying off the debt because i have a
year to find my own
place okay my roommates are moving in
april and the town i live in
it's expensive to rent it's about 800 a
month yeah
and if i would get a house that would be
even bigger than what i can get for 800
a month my mortgages would look about
550 to 650 a month
yeah but i tell everyone just because
the mortgage is cheaper than your rent
doesn't mean your house is cheaper than
your apartment
all day every day so um i get the fact
that you're looking at your mortgage
payment but i i promise you your water
bill goes up your electricity bill goes
up
your you got to cut the grass you got to
maintain the grass you got to maintain
the house
so right now renting for you is the best
option
because you just pay your rent and just
maintain the interior of the house
but if anything breaks your landlord is
responsible for that so
right now renting for you is the best
option uh because you don't want to go
purchase a house and you don't even have
you know a thousand dollars sitting in
your savings account you don't have any
money for an emergency
so what i want you to do is walk through
the baby steps number one you're gonna
put a thousand dollars in your savings
account
uh number two you're gonna pay off all
the rest of this twenty four hundred
dollars
and then number three you're gonna set
aside three to six months all right
so you're already on baby step number
four in baby step number two ruby so
what i want to do is stop investing
i understand you got the match from your
employer but that five percent can help
you get out of this twenty four hundred
dollars
very very well now i'm not telling you
to withdraw
from your 401k i'm just telling you to
pause
putting money into your 401k so you can
put
more money towards this 2400 and stack
up
three to six months now let's talk about
your job
i want to connect you with our career
expert here called ken coleman
because i do believe that you need to
get your income up so that way you can
at least get to around around 2 500 to 3
000
take home a month so that way you can
get into the house that you want
so here i'm say this again and then i'm
gonna let dr john come in number one
no you're not a position to purchase a
home number two
stop investing use that five percent to
go towards
all of your paying off your debt but
before you pay off your debt ruby
put a thousand dollars in your savings
account okay so you're gonna make all
your minimum payments get a thousand
dollars in your savings account
then go back to aggressively attacking
this twenty four hundred dollars
while you're doing all that you're gonna
get on the phone and i'm next week
ruby i want you to call in to the ken
coleman show and i want you to ask ken
coleman how can i get my income up
hey ruby how soon how recent was your
divorce over
my divorce was
[Applause]
it was officialized in 2016. okay
so you're still rebounding from it
several years later huh
yeah it's just because of the amount of
the debt and honestly how expensive it
is in this town
yeah what is the what's the allure of
that town
the lure of the town is one of the
benefits
to me my children are native okay
and this is where our tribe is at there
you go okay
i benefited from my child and for my
employer there's actually really great
health benefits
and there's really great like i said the
retirement it's
vacation it's like when coveted i had
the opportunity to work from home so
that i could still be here when my kids
weren't allowed to go to school that's
right
and so i've got a close close friend um
who is in a tribe there in oklahoma city
um absolutely understand that
and understand the community and the
resources you got there too
i need you to hear me and anthony tell
you you are in a financial emergency
and that that's that heart racing that
you experience all the time
that frustration you have with
getting to the end of the month and here
it is five years later and you're still
paying off twelve thousand dollars worth
of debt
you're balancing you're trading this so
this a false safety
for if you listen to what anthony's
gonna tell you
you're talking about legacy change you
were talking about being able to sleep
in a way you haven't slept
in years ruby okay and so
and instead of trying to get on some
kind of hud loan so you can do christmas
every year i want you to be able to
go to the store with your own cash in
your own place and it's going to be hard
and it may mean you got to get a
different employer
millions and millions and millions of
people worked from home this past year
to be with their kids and millions and
millions of people
have good health care many people don't
have health care but there's a lot of
options
i want you to hang on the line we're
going to give you a copy of ramsay plus
and i want you to go sit through all
these lessons
and i want you to look at it with new
eyes yeah and just
think that's good wow what would happen
if
i could sleep all night yeah
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neill joined in the studio
with me is dr john daloni
two ramsey personalities taking your
phone calls
answering your questions right here
triple eight eight two five
five two two five we have one phone line
open right now
but keep calling madison will get you
through as soon as possible
but i got a question for you guys uh
anyone interested in working
uh with us here at ramsey solutions well
if so we want to transform so many lives
that disruption spreads like wildfire
across our country can you imagine a
world where it is
weird extremely rare to have a student
loan
instead of everyone assuming that's the
only way to get an education
oh i would love that world can you
imagine a world where the majority of
people pay
cash for their dream cars can you also
imagine a world
where credit cards are the cigarette of
the financial industry
imagine being a part of causing that
level of disruption
with the work you do every single day
here at ram solutions that's why we have
a thousand people at our company working
together to create digital products and
services
to help people transform their lives
with the goal of disrupting the toxic
money culture that exists in america
today so
if you want to join us on this crusade
we're currently on the hunt for many
software engineers with expert expertise
in ruby on rails java c-sharp and
front-end technologies
or if you are a ux designer seo
and content marketing specialist we
would also
love to be with you can we just stop
that for a second what's up
none of those jobs existed when i was
getting out of college there's zero of
them
none of those jobs i don't think existed
10 years ago i didn't even understand
what a a ux designer
all the things you just said
[Laughter]
wow but you know but here's the thing
though john we have so many
other jobs like for example i'm looking
for a video producer and uh
you're looking for someone to make sure
you make it to work on time so
if you want them uh join this amazing
team here at ramsey solutions
and really help us take over uh the
world with our message our god-fearing
message
i want you to text the word work that
matters
text work that matters to 33789 again
that is work
that matters to 33789 to find out
about all of our opportunities and y'all
we are on a mission you know if if when
you come here to the studio
you will see that we have a another
building going up
uh and so dave um
and the family and our board here you
know we're we're we're trying to get
some
we're trying to really take over so we
need hundreds
of new team members to join us so if you
want to come work for an organization
that's transforming lives
that that's helping people um hey text
the word
work that matters to 33789 wherever you
are we will help you move here
because we want thoroughbreds uh to join
us
if you're a donkey stay home uh let's go
out to spokane and have a conversation
with doug doug good afternoon how can dr
john and i help
hey dr donogh great to talk to you guys
and
god bless you and all of dave's team for
all the help you guys provide
it's definitely helped me in my life for
sure
awesome um so i got
some issues with trying to deal with my
my son's
mom we were really good at co-parenting
for the
most part and everybody's a wonderful
son
but occasionally there's these nuclear
bombs that come
from text messages of changing things or
she didn't like how i did something
and it's a hard thing to deal with
and to and respond to in the right way
without getting emotional
and you know taking a conversation down
a path that
is probably not the best way for it to
go give me an example of a nuclear bomb
well so the latest instance is i am
getting remarried
this summer and we were discussing
handoffs around what to do he's going to
be in the wedding
and all this and i'm like hey he'll stay
with my mom and dad the night of and
you know come pick him up in the morning
and then she
two days later after we decided that
said no i'm not comfortable with them
staying there
i'm going to come pick them up that
night and i'll take it
and just in a text message and i have no
i have to
respond to that somehow so
what about that message so somebody just
expressed sounds like a relatively
benign boundary i'm not comfortable with
that i'll come get him
and so what about that a is a nuclear
bomb b why do you have to respond to
that
c why do you allow that to get into your
soul
and ruin what's going to be an awesome
summer event for you
great question um
well i guess because she's just
she's not okay with him staying with
my mom and dad because for some reason
she's not comfortable for some reason
she doesn't she doesn't trust them to
take care
of him and there's no evidence in the
past
for that so i guess that's why that bugs
me
and i thought we were under agreement i
felt good about things and then
two days later this comes in she's
changing the plan on her own without
really talking through it and and when
is this this is months away from now
yeah end of july okay so
man
i i don't want to i don't want to
minimize what you're experiencing okay
i trust you that this hurts and i trust
you this is frustrating you're trying to
outline these plans
okay um yeah if that's why
i'm calling you because i i trust your
advice well i appreciate that
so um i want you to do some reframing
when it comes to nuclear bombs
okay that is this doesn't feel like a
nuclear bomb to me this feels like
um it's gonna be hard for her to watch
you get remarried and
she doesn't want to do x y and z y'all
can have that conversation okay
um the second thing is
if it's not a big deal if this if it's
not staying with your parents
if if you're talking about changing
things by 24 hours
let her change things by 24 hours this
is an existential conversation not a
planning issue
right so um letting this affect your
wedding
man don't let it affect your wedding
then the third thing is
you are free to say hey i don't want to
have conversations via text anymore
electronic communication anymore um
let's let's have a schedule time where
we talk once a week
you can respond with boundaries in an
appropriate way too does that make sense
yes that does make sense i guess i guess
my bigger question is why are you
allowing her to have this power over you
that's a good question well that is a
good question and
it's she kind of puts things back on me
you know
as as a dad sometimes we make
make some mistakes and um
you know and are and also we're
different people we plan different what
what we feel is is safe or cool or fun
is different for each of us and and
those don't line up and i think because
you know obviously we're not married
anymore there's
there's no grace coming from from her
side in
letting me make decisions that i think
would be
fun for for our son and to help him
experience his life sure 100 get that
what's in the divorce decree are you
being extra generous here
no i mean the divorce decree i mean it
we
and we don't really follow it we've been
really good with
things up until like last year kind of
when when
the covid guidelines hit and my fiance
she kind of lives in a different town so
you know we had travel restrictions in
the state and we
had a lot of issues over it well i'm
going to see her she didn't want me to
because you're supposed to stay at home
there you go hey so listen listen
you are now your ex-wife right wrong or
indifferent and again i'm trying to just
give you a broad picture
she is now going to experience not only
she's going to experience you
moving on with your life and that's
going to be hard
and there's going to be the safety
issues that she felt with coven
fair enough right right wrong or
indifferent fair enough
and now there's this there's an
impending wedding coming
okay it's going to be hard is it right
no is it annoying yes
is she allowed to to mourn you moving on
yes
go back to the divorce decree man
there's a reason those things are
written down
if you have a right to certain times
with your kid
go by that divorce decree and if you
don't you don't but don't give her this
much power
okay if you don't like what's in a text
call her we we we're going to talk about
this after
break you said she has a right to mourn
him moving on
oh she does i gotta ask more questions
about that cool okay we'll be right back
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show my
name is anthony o'neill ramsey
personality joined in the studio with me
and co-hosting together
uh ramsay personality national
best-selling author dr john deloney
we're taking your phone calls triple
eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two
five and before we went to break it was
it was a good call and i didn't say much
on it because you were the expert in
that area but i have a question
um as a product of four parents
my biological parents having me out of
wedlock
one of the things i really loved about
all four of my parents
um was i didn't see or feel
much drama between them oh man so they
actually communicated like grown-ups
from what i can remember now if it
actually happened
hey i don't know you know what i'm
saying like yeah i don't know but
i was wondering from your from your
chair and i think it's an important
conversation
just to ask and we're gonna get back to
the phone calls um
but do you believe that it is it is a
good idea to when a
couple has a divorce uh to actually go
to maybe one or two counseling sessions
just solely on how do we properly
communicate
as we are going our separate ways to
raise this child
oh man because it's like children see
and
feel they absorb it yeah everything so
if they see mom is giving dead a hard
time or dad is giving mom a hard time
i just feel as if that's new so if
do you think it'll be a wise idea
because i again i'm not married i'm just
asking the question to the expert
um is it a wise idea for maybe couples
to to kind of mature up a little
bit set aside their differences and go
get some mentorship
on how to do this moving forward yeah
and
man that's such a great question anthony
part of me thinks if they were mature
enough to do that
they possibly could have headed off some
of these relational challenges in the
past
but let's let's assume we're past that
it it sometimes shocks people
when i ask him a question i get that he
or she was a terrible
spouse yeah but were they a good dad or
a good mom and they'll go
oh yeah they're really good at being a
mom really good at showing up being a
dad
they just weren't good over here so yeah
man if couples are headed that way if
they are getting divorced in the process
getting some guidance putting your drama
down for the sake of
the one two three five seven kids is
everything because you're right they
will absorb it
literally changes their chemistry
absolutely right absolutely
um and any way you can avoid you know
what that last caller is going through
yeah and people grow up in in things
change it's different rate uh
co-parenting
a three-year-old and a five-year-old
than it is a 13 and a 17 year old right
that's just different so yeah checking
back in
you're going to be a part of each
other's life regardless so man get some
advice and get some guidance and do that
part right
yeah absolutely man i just had to ask
that question i love it because a lot of
people
are listening to this right now are
going through the same thing that
they're going through
yeah and i and i just wanted to let let
the world know like hey there's nothing
wrong with having a simple conversation
how do we do this properly moving
forward
right because it does impact i love
children good for your folks man that's
great man
my folks are amazing i love you mommy
and daddy i love you
uh sam is with us in portland good
afternoon sam how can
dr d and i help hi there um
so i'm 25 years old and i just finished
baby step
three and i'm wanting to begin the
process
for going to pa school okay and it's a
little ways away
but i'm wanting to know where as i save
money to cash flow
my tuition where should i place it
should i put it in a 529 should i put it
in
just a general mutual fund um where's
the best place
um how much is pa school going to cost
you and how much time
uh how long would it be before you
actually go to uh school
yeah i've done some research um on pa
schools here in oregon but then also in
other places to see
what so it's probably gonna be anywhere
between 75 and a hundred thousand
dollars
okay um i make about fifty thousand
dollars right now i work three jobs
um and save minimal expenses so i saved
a lot of money every month okay um it's
probably going to be about two years
away because i'm in a job contract right
now that i can't break
um before i can start school so i love
you planning ahead sam you're making my
whole heart feel good man good for you
i have a question that you may not like
but it's a good question
why yeah i've always wanted i'm an emt
right now and i've always wanted to do
i i thought i wanted to be a doctor and
then i really started looking at
what physician assistants do and looking
at some of the community oriented
programs that they're a part of i've
always wanted to be
one of those community um doctors you
know that run that like
works in the small town clinic that gets
to serve everyone from
you know the new baby to the elderly i
just love that idea
i love it i love it i love it so you'll
go from 55 to uh what's your
what's your good what's your income
ballpark around that uh once you finish
school
um i would do some research any like
starting out
probably 85 to 80 to 80 to 90
depending on where i get a job and then
from there
you know upwards it just depends on on
where you work and what you do
cool great great well here's here's a
good thing sam you're out of debt
you got your fully funded emergency fund
um i would definitely say go ahead and
start
on baby step four start investing uh but
because you're looking at school within
the next two years no
do not put into a 529 i'll just put into
a money market account
and just park it there so that way you
can have access to it
because this is not a loan term you're
not looking at something five years plus
if you're looking at something five
years plus i would say just put in a
regular mutual fund
but since it's shorter than that just go
ahead and just park it into your money
market account
and from there you'll be all right okay
all right thank you you're awesome good
luck sam i like that i really do like
that good luck sam
uh ruchi is with us in washington dc
good afternoon ruchi
how can dr d and i help hi thanks for
taking my call
yeah uh so i have a question um my
husband and i we
are fortunate that we don't have any
debt uh besides our mortgage
um however we do have a liability in the
sense that we financially support
my husband's parents who live abroad
okay we send about
on average about 800 a month for their
living expenses
and you know if there was any sort of
medical
emergency or something by the other
emergency we would also cover that
okay so my question to you is in what
step or how would you consider this
particular
you know quote unquote liability within
the baby steps
um and then outside of that monthly
expense that we send
we're having a hard time quantifying you
know what sort of emergency may
come up and so how would you look at
that how would you quantify it and then
where do you put this in the baby step
and how do we how do we approach that
that's a good question uh and i love you
two's heart
so um how old are um how old are they
they're so there's three of them it's
his mother
father and an aunt and they're all above
70 years old
mother he's y'all are helping provide
for the mother the father
and his aunt yeah so
they're in india right so they grew up
in a joint family so the three of them
operated you know as like the parent
so all right um so all right
sounds good so right now what baby step
are you on
so we um we don't have any debt
we we save for our retirement we we save
for our
child's colleges how much money do you
have in your emergency fund
uh it's fully funded for about like four
to four to six months
okay four to six months all right so
here's what i'm going to recommend um
uh i'm not going to get into the whole
mom
father thing i think if you're if you're
sending them 800
right now and that's helping them out i
would just definitely say just go ahead
and put another three months of 800
so what's that 20 24 2400
um just extra on top of your emergency
fund
so that way if something does happen to
them you have
that extra money that does not impact
you
um or your family if you have to send
them twenty four hundred dollars
uh for an emergency um and that eight
hundred dollars just becomes a
i mean you just budget for it and you're
it's not really a baby step as much as a
budget
yeah right it's just a budget item you
know it's not debt um
but it is something that hey if if
something does happen to them next month
um you may need to send more than 800
right and so i would definitely tell
them
like hey the most we can do um it's 800
a month and you all know the most we can
do in one lump sum is 2 400
uh but here's the thing ruchi i want to
make sure that you and your husband
do not um oh
i don't want to sound rude here but i
just want to make sure that your family
is your priority and that everything is
okay there
they come after your home okay help
where you can
but make sure you're not pulling away
from your actual house
that's just my two cents in there am i
missing anything there john there's some
cultural implications there that are
hard for every family but i think it's
just being practical with here's what we
can do
right and we're going to be smart both
in the short term and the long term with
savings plans
sounds good well america that's a wrap
for this first hour thank you james
child thank you madison and uh
hey this is the ramsay show
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit
daveramsey.com show and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
and your money my name is anthony o'neil
host of the popular youtube and podcast
show the table
with anthony o'neil and co-hosting with
me today is the one and only national
best-selling author dr john deloney the
host of the
dr john deloney show and together we're
going to be
answering your questions taking your
phone calls
if you have any questions around your
life around your money
around relationships around your mental
health around
anxiety around depression around
boyfriend girlfriend stuff around
married couple stuff hey listen
uh this is the ramsay show we want to
help you out in every area of your life
and give you some guidance give you some
um answers
so give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five
five two two five and uh we'll have a
conversation with you
how's the show coming man i was just
still marveling at how you managed to
pull off
naming your show the table oh man you
know it's all good
that's an inside joke for those of us
who thought hey what if we didn't name
the show after
ourselves and i lost that clearly
we had a lot of meetings to come up with
the creatively titled
but the dr john deloney show is a great
title bro it is
and it's doing well my mom name yeah man
it's it's just
it's just on a rocket ship we're having
fun um i don't pay a lot of attention to
that stuff as
as much as the calls that are coming in
and the amount of calls people are
reaching out so it's really great man
new episodes every monday wednesday and
friday on youtube and anywhere you
listen to podcasts
this man is really doing a great great
great job helping people out with their
mental health so listen check this out
if you have a question for him um not
only can you ask him the questions right
here on the ramsay show but you can
email
ask john ramseysolutions.com again
that's
ask john ramsey solutions.com or leave a
voicemail
at 844-693-329-1
again that is 844-693-3291
and for a chance to have your question
featured on
his show and this man gets some
interesting questions that i'm
so grateful uh well the company is
probably grateful
i'm not on the other side answering the
question hey one day you're going to
come on the show
and you're gonna answer the calls live
as they come in hey man we're just gonna
get ourselves cancelled
and be done listen listen man i think
the people will love my answer
i'll just get a phone call from dave
that would be the truth
oh man but give us a call you guys
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we're here for this hour to take
your questions uh and joshua's with us
in new york city good afternoon joshua
how can dr d and i help
hey good afternoon anthony thanks for
having me on no thank you for calling in
background sorry about that quick
background for my question
i am 23 married with one kid currently
on active duty and i'm considering
transitioning back to civilian life
i am looking at using my va loan to buy
a house okay
um so a little bit of our financial
situation we're debt-free we have about
30 000 in savings uh currently
investment
16 with a five percent match into tsp
um so we figure we can afford about a
two hundred thousand dollar house
uh with twenty thousand down um my
question is should i spend that much
time
should i buy something cheaper and put
the twenty thousand into renovating it
um i think that's totally up to you
joshua you know my whole thing
is uh with that va loan just be very
careful i want you to put down at least
20 percent
um 10 to 20 actually 20 so you can
avoid some other stuff within it um
personally more more of a conventional
loan to be honest as well
but as far as in the kind of house that
you purchase
um i um it's really up to you in your
family if you all
want to get into a house that you
actually mark up not markup that you
build up that's fine as well
but the meltdown has nothing to do with
that though
the amount down goes down to i want you
to avoid the pmi
and i want you to have equity in your
house and you need at least 20 percent
equity in your home to avoid a private
mortgage insurance
that would be also attached to your loan
so
i'm going to say always stick to that 20
going down
bare minimum is 10 um but if you want to
get a house with 20
down to buy something that you can do a
fixer-upper
uh that's fine but if this is gonna be
your family's home
forever home uh then man i'm actually
going with something newer
and i'm just gonna just go that route so
i don't that way i don't have any
headaches
joshua i think it's a personal decision
between with you and your wife
um i i tend towards
buying a less expensive house anthony
likes his stuff fancier than me
and i'm not even i mean that's not uh
that's facts knocking anybody yeah
everybody just does that a little bit
different i like to spend my money in
other places and so i think that's just
gonna be a personal decision
i would before you just go sign on a va
loan
do call and um
call the mortgage company that's not
associated with the va
yeah um that you are gonna get a higher
rate sometimes with the va and if you've
got that much money down there's no
sense in
even going through it if it's not the
best rate and they're not gonna treat
you right right so
call churchill mortgage get a good rate
with from them and
let them know that you're a veteran and
have them walk you through that process
yeah
i totally respect the veteran process uh
but i agree with dr d
here uh i would definitely call church
for morgan see if he can get into a
not see get into a convention alone with
that 20 percent down
and you'll be better off there um i can
almost guarantee you
um on that um and you know what dr d
this this is what i like to tell people
is you just said something that's so
good you you would tend to go towards a
cheaper
um home i do like myself probably a
little bit more fancier
there's nothing wrong with either one of
us
no because we worked hard we followed
the baby steps
and we worked hard so we can do
what we want to do right um you know you
like going you know shooting and
and um hunting i i don't that ain't me
right you like golfing
i like golfing you know what i'm saying
but yeah who wants to sit out there in
the cold weather waiting
on deers to come by all day he wants to
chase a silly
white ball all day yes
me just dragging a bag of clubs hey
yes come on man but see here's the thing
though america
once you actually do the work you do the
work so you can have freedom
and options to do what you want to
do right and i think that's the beauty
of this plan
is you're going to live like no one else
so you can live
like no one else so you can live the way
you and your
family wants to live stop
stop america say oh you should do that
you should go buy a dave car well listen
here
um i don't think well i'm gonna say that
uh but dave carr doesn't have to be a
hooptie
okay you know um you can literally do
what you want to do and that's one thing
that i really want people to know is
like hey
you know make the best decision for you
and your family loans your debt free
loans you got a fully funded emergency
fund and you're investing into your
future
make the decision that's best for you i
may not like your decision but who cares
if you're debt free you follow the baby
steps
go do you and that's why you got friends
to come over and give you a hard time on
your front porch
about your decisions right yeah to laugh
at you about playing golf for god's sake
oh my goodness man you know i
you know what hey listen me and dave
love playing i'd say you could be like
old man and
dave does both of them dave does dave
does and he's good at both of them too
especially the hunting part black jesus
i love it
825-5225 we're here one more hour with
you all
right here on the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neill rams personality
joins in the studio with me is dr john
deloney
also a ramsey personality and james is
with us
in austin texas good afternoon james how
can dr d
and i help yes i was calling to see um
how do i help my mother get current on
her bill as well and baby step number
two
while you are in baby set number two um
james
yes sir okay cool um how much uh debt
are you currently in right now
uh right now i have uh i mean it's a car
loan
i'm consolidated it's probably about 17
grand
or two it's it's consolidated
when you say consolidated what you mean
what do you mean like
i have two two car notes on one
oh okay okay i got you all right all
right gotcha
two cars all right and um
now what's what's the responsibility
with your mom well what's
are you trying to help her with her car
no her credit card bills too
uh no sir i'm just trying to help her at
least get caught up on her bills like as
far as
everyday residential bills oh like
lights
gas utility stuff like that yes sir and
by what's the ballpark of that
um currently uh she just doesn't make
enough and i heard she's having health
problems so she can't really uh
do much as far as she just works part
time right now
okay so what's the what is the if you
get a current today
what does it look like next what does it
look like um april 1st
and may 1st it's probably going to be
continuous honestly
okay is she in his is she is shaw's
relationship
such that you could sit down and talk to
her about moving
coming up with a new plan um or is
this well i know these messy situations
where she's just
is going to do what she's going to do
and that you have to make hard hard
choices
but i mean
i've tried to talk to her about it
there's days that she seems like she's
on board others that she's not
but um it's just one of those deals then
another day she's just not making much
income and due to her health
problems she can't really do much as far
as an actual
nine-to-five job are you the only child
james
uh no sir i have uh two other brothers
okay and are they trying to help as well
um
they do when they can uh one of them's
still uh underage
the other one uh is working and he's
uh in a mess himself as far as financial
goals
when you say uh underage so you have a
little brother still living at home in
this situation
yes i do and that's
that's what i'm uh i feel like i'm kind
of trapped because uh
i mean at the end of the day i mean not
only
that she has uh like health problems
it's
kind of hard to see them her fall
and my younger brother just there to
fall with her because i mean you can't
really do much yeah
how do you request james i'm 23.
okay you married um
i'm engaged engaged ah okay
um so this is a hard situation that's
gonna
um here's here's the challenge for you
um one you've got a little brother here
you got a minor in a situation and
if your mom falls too far behind if her
health problems become
too too big of a situation where she
can't take care of him
um he's gonna get taken out of that
house and you know that
um but you also don't want to see your
mom get
um get foreclosed on right get her home
taken away or become homeless
and at the same time you're not in a
position to do a whole lot of help and
so you end up
trying to float till the next month into
the next month and then it just turns
into this cyclical cycle of
cyclical cycle that's that was redundant
but you end up in this situation that
never gets any better
right so what you've got to do less
than um worried about the baby steps at
this point
you've got to get all of your brothers
in a room you got to get your mom in a
room
and you all have to have a map it out
plan it out
truth-telling conversation and if mom
can't hear it doesn't want to be on
board
then what you're going to have to do is
figure out a situation for your little
brother
whether you invite him to come live with
you or one of your other brothers can
take care of him
you've got a minor that you got to deal
with and i'm worried about him getting
taken away
and number two i don't know if you got
to sit down with social security whether
you got to sit down with
with community resources there in austin
i know there's a million community
resources there
but you're at a place now where the
action is not
hey how can i get a few more extra bucks
to help this thing because this thing is
systemic
this thing is ongoing so somebody and
i'm looking at you now because you
called us
has to plant a flag in the yard and say
no more
as a group as a family i'm calling
this part's over we may all have to work
a little bit differently it may be three
or four
years of us doing things that we don't
want to be doing to help out mom to help
out little brother
to change the entire trajectory of the
ship
but man just saying hey how do i budget
this is a bigger bigger deal than that
right
and this is not gonna be easy no it's
not your brothers are gonna hate on you
your mother's gonna look at you and say
who do you think you are talking to me
your little brother's probably got his
friends and his community
it's gonna be hard but somebody's gotta
turn and stare down this forest fire and
say no more
right and i think the turning point for
me was when you said hey even if i
caught my mother uh my mother up today
uh we're gonna have the same problems
going into the next month right so
james here is my and everyone listening
in america
and i say this all the time your home
is your priority okay there's nothing
wrong
with telling your parents hey i can help
but here's my limit if that's a hundred
dollars a month
that's your limit you are helping if you
are not
in a position to help there is nothing
wrong with saying hey
i cannot help i have a responsibility to
take care of my home
to set to set myself up to be able to
provide for me
and my future wife that's my
responsibility
and so i think before you go to this
meeting because dr d
is right you have to have a family
meeting before you go to that family
meeting
you need to sit down look at your budget
uh because paying off your debt is your
priority
but i have no problem with you saying
hey mom i'm gonna give you a hundred
dollars
because i understand you're going
through a health issue you have some
other stuff so here's 100 bucks here's
200.
here's that number that doesn't hurt you
and prevent you
from paying and attacking your debt
because you are about to be married
the last thing i want you to do man and
hear me clearly is get married and now
you and your wife are having
arguments about your mom that is and
that's your mother outside of your house
and and i want to be sensitive because
if my parents were hurting
i mean i'm going to help but i would
definitely say i'm going to help
but there's a limit at my hope um and i
think the responsibility has to come
back on your mom
to really step up and to really start
taking care of herself and her son
or allow herself to be taken care of
right which may mean we got to sell this
house
yeah we gonna have to move down to a one
bedroom right
so it may be that her health problems
and
any number of other issues aren't going
to allow her to
get to go get another job to go work
three jobs to to pick this up but
you got to allow yourself then to be
helped right you have to you have to
all right so today's blinds.com find out
for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one
online retailer of custom window
covering you get free samples free
shipping with the new promos they run
every month you'll save
even more use promo code ramsey to get
the best deal
rules and restrictions apply anthony i
can't wait to get your answer on this
today's question comes from scott in
detroit
my oldest son doesn't want to play high
school football anymore
and i feel like i've been punched in the
gut how do i get over
being disappointed about this
this is this is a real question that's a
real question
my oh you got punched in the gut because
your son says he doesn't he doesn't want
to get punched in the gut
i mean you're the expert on this uh i'm
i'm asking you
so take football out um i think your son
has the right to choose what sports and
what activities he desires to do
it it's not your son's job to live your
dreams or the dreams you didn't
accomplish
and it sounds like the father is upset
that you know his son is not playing a
sport that he really wanted to play
and so it's bad for us to push our
dreams onto our children when they're
they're not theirs
we have a society of parents living
vicariously through their children
they i want them to get grades so i can
go tell somebody i want to play soccer
so that i can
tell my kids that my kid got a soccer
scholarship what scott go hug your son
go hug go hug your son and then be a
comacello fan or a
flute plant fan or whatever he's going
to do be a fan of your son
not what your son does that's it man
let's stop
i'm not gonna sit down this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neill ramsey personality
number one national bestselling author
of the book debt free degree
and joining me in the studio today is
also
a national best-selling author um and
the host of the dr john delaney show the
one and only doctor
john deloney so anthony hey you hit a
big milestone
with the anthony o'neill youtube channel
the show tell us what's going on oh man
we're just
impacting lives having a real relevant
and relatable conversation around how to
build true wealth and get out of debt
and
really start building healthy
relationships man you know and so
uh we're growing rapidly fast over there
um doing our show over there
and a lot of people you know ask
questions and some people get offended
but i mean um
you know my audience is i really have a
heart for that younger generation the 18
to about 34
because i think we do a lot for the
adults i think we do a lot for that
older generation but
um i think the best time to hit them is
when they're 18 it's when they're 19
when they're 20 when they just
not now leaving the house because i
remember that season when i left my
house
at 18 year years old i racked up 35
000 in debt 15 000 in credit card
10 000 in furniture bill from a
particular furniture store i would not
name here
um and then ten thousand dollars in
student loans and and when i really
stepped back and looked at why
why did i make those decisions it was
because i was trying to impress
my peers i was trying to impress the
ladies just to be honest
um i was trying to look like how i
wanted to be received
rather than actually just be who god
made me to be
and um culture the world
the community said hey this is how you
have to be this is how you have to look
this is how you have to act to be
successful and to be respected
and so i wrapped up all that debt at the
age of 18 man um and made some
some some dumb decisions just to be real
got into an argument with my father
thought i was a grown man when i wasn't
a grown man um i ended up homeless
sleeping in the back of my car for a
period of my life
all because of the poor decisions that i
made and so
when i look at my brand now it's like
man i really want to speak to that 18
year old
i really want to speak to that 19 year
old i have a heart for everyone but my
passion is really to that
that young person 18 to 34 who who if
they just avoid debt man they can be
wealthy and retired when they turn 45 50
years old if they
can avoid debt avoid taking out student
loans and graduate
college and land a job making 80 000 to
100 000
a year and they start investing 15
percent of their income now they're
focusing on building their last name and
purchasing homes at a young age and
starting businesses at a young age and
so
over at the table man with anthony
o'neil i'm having that real
relevant culture talk i'm going against
what culture is teaching
um and i'm attacking it you know so the
language over there is a little
different
um but it's because i'm going after a
particular culture that is saying hey
uh to be cool to be sexy to be half swag
you got to be in debt you got to be like
this no i think
being saved being debt free being
married to one woman being married to
one man
that's the new cool that's the new sexy
and so that's the conversation we're
having over there man just keeping it
real relevant i love it man well it's
it's
it's it sounds like people are desperate
for somebody to cut through the nonsense
and just tell them the truth
oh yeah right yeah to listen to actually
listen
yeah and then to provide absolutely
absolute truth right thanks for asking
for that man but america if you all know
anybody or this is you
um in that age bracket man send them
over you know they can go over to my
instagram at anthony o'neill or go over
to my youtube channel
that is also the table with anthony
o'neill man we are at 220
000 subscribers i don't know what god is
doing but just last january we only had
like 43 000 subscribers and
now we're at 223 i'm like okay god
you're up to something so
we're doing something right over there
man so appreciate you you was on the
show
and uh you rocked it and so i love it
rachel was on the show it was amazing so
we gotta get dave on the show i gotta
talk to him first before we get on the
show
make sure dave no hey man this is you
know these are young people these are a
little cool
you know can you you know i'm gonna keep
my job and keep my mouth shut
at the same time triple eight eight two
five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two
five uh dr d and myself here anthony
o'neil are taking your phone calls about
money about life about anything so give
us a call one line just opened up
madison sitting there looking at it
saying hey we got one line
uh so uh give her a call uh keenan is
with us in lincoln good afternoon keenan
this is anthony and dr d how can we help
uh hey actually i'm sorry that was kevin
not keenan but uh
oh what's up kevin problem oh okay i
appreciate it appreciate it um
so uh my wife and i were on baby steps
four five and six
um uh
let's see sorry i lost my train of
thought there um we're on
basis four five and six um we take home
usually probably maybe two thousand
dollars
more a month a month than our expenses
we're paying extra on the house of
course we're putting our 15
to retirement and um
my question is what is a reasonable
amount that we
can uh budget for
uh you know fund money for just personal
expenses that we don't have to clear
with each other
um that's kind of our own business you
know i've got a lot of hobbies my wife
not so much um so you know
what uh what's a reasonable amount to
set aside
i mean i think the reasonable amount uh
kevin is going to be
really based upon you and your wife's
comfort zone okay
uh once you sit down and you all are
very detailed with the budget which just
sounds like you guys are
um i'm assuming that you're already debt
free and you have a fully funded
emergency fund
and so because you're already on baby
says four through seven um and so do you
have any kids right now kevin
no no kids no kids all right cool so
you're all doing 15 percent of baby set
number four and you're switching over to
babysit number six
paying the extra mortgage so you're in a
perfect situation and so i think for you
like something that i've um
actually have my parents doing right now
um my dad actually
in their budget line has a certain
amount of money
that my mom can just go out there and
spend my mom is a coupon shopper she
loves couponing
and she can go couponing every single
day and so my dad was like hey i don't
want you to call and ask me every single
day can you spend
ten dollars like go spend ten dollars
and so they have a line item
on their budget in every dollar that
says it just says
wifey's aka mama because i give her some
money as well
um to shop and so if that budget is safe
for an example 500
my mom just knows she has 500 but here's
the thing
she updates the budget every single day
so if she spends 20 dollars she puts 20
inside of every dollar and she knows she
has 480
left to spend within that budget so i
think
from you and your wife to sit down be
very very
detailed but then also before you
actually say hey
uh kevin you can spend 500 on golfing or
in your hobbies
baby you can spend 500 on this i would
actually have an extra cushion
for unexpected expenses for the family
so for an example i would say
here's a thousand dollars that's for
unexpected things that may come up we
may say hey let's drive down to the
beach and just
get a room this month uh and just
celebrate something i don't know
i would have just an extra cushion on
your budget then below
that have different spending amounts
that you all can enjoy because
i'm gonna have that too because i'm a
golfer um i love playing basketball
and so um i love to just do that and i
don't want to have to ask my wife
hey bae i want to go golfing today with
the boys you know i'm gonna go do this
and
hey kevin did this did this pop up on a
particular incident
uh well yeah so i i previously had a
side hustle of uh doing a bicycle taxi
for
husker home games and arena events and
that that kind of
that took care of my personal expenses
then and you know that was just kind of
my money
that i was earning on the side well
kovit of course shut that down in the
last year
so um i took a different job a little
part-time
uh saturday job and i was miserable at
it yeah and
um i just recently put in my two-week
notice with it
and told my wife you know i'm just we're
just gonna have to start taking from
our full-time job paychecks for some of
these you know fun expenses that i have
and she
wasn't super happy about that but my
thought process was gosh you know
um we're doing everything right you know
and we're on baby steps four five and
six you know i should be able to
spend a little money here and there um
as long as we're still staying on track
with our goals
to you know spend on personal expenses
without you know having to have the nose
to the grindstone
and you're both right kevin you're both
right
working side hustle so you can quote
unquote have my money and you can't
touch my money
that's gonna cause problems down the
road as you're experiencing now
and at the same time um yeah i get
wanting to spend
like have some fun play right so sit
down have a hard conversation with each
other y'all get on the same page you'll
get to square it up man y'all good folks
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show my name
is anthony o'neill sitting in joining
me in the studio today is dr john
deloney triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two
five it's a number to give us a call
right now we have one phone line just
opened up
uh but before we jump back to the phone
lines uh i want to tell y'all a quick
story
uh in about 30 seconds i remember
in oceanside california john i was on
i was at the beach i was in my car and i
was sitting there
just with my friends and on this day a
lot of my friends pulled up in mercedes
pulled up in
bmws pulled up in lexuses pulled up in
you name it some real nice highline cars
and back in these days back in the 2000s
you know you had the the the spinner
wheels so when you stopped
they kept going the wheels kept going
right right and so that was a big thing
back in the day so
see they out there laughing at me the
young was like what is he talking about
and the other one's like yeah i remember
that
um and so we looked like we had money
we we looked like we were bawling
but when my boy stepped out of one of
his cars me and my boy said man you know
what a dude driving a fifty thousand
dollar car
but he lives at home in his mom's
basement
another dude jumped out of his car to go
to the beach and he's like hey man
that's that's such-and-such and dude
don't he stay with like six
other brothers in the house and when we
looked at everyone including ourselves
we all looked like we had money but we
were living paycheck
to paycheck all of us had debt all of us
was just
we had the look but we didn't have
the money and that was the day i left
that beach saying
i am not going to be this guy anymore
i changed things around i already had a
job
i went out there and got two more jobs
after i got out got off of my full-time
job man
i went and watched cars and then i
started delivering newspapers in the
evening
because i was like i'm sick and tired of
being sick and tired i'm sick and tired
of looking like how i have
looking like i have some money but i
have no
money okay but i want to stop right
there because i think that's an
important moment that people get hung up
on you had this moment of clarity
right right um i like to call it a thin
space when
suddenly everything gets real clear
right and then
you said today is this day yeah whether
i'm going to get out of debt i'm going
to lose weight i'm going to be
a better husband i'm going to get some
new tools because i know i'm not being
the dad i need to be filling the blank
yeah
and then that's when it gets real hard
yes
yes it's not when everything you wake up
the next day and it's all good right you
do that first workout and you are so
sore that fall that you can't move
yeah yeah you go tell everybody how to
be a new dad and they'll roll their eyes
at you right
or hey i'm getting out of i'm getting
another job no job and your guys are
like all right cool we're still going to
the beach
right and suddenly you find yourself all
by yourself right
yeah that's right when it starts getting
hard and then you find yourself
two weeks three weeks two months three
months six months and you're lonely
you're exhausted you're sore you fill in
the blank right
right what kept you going yeah i mean
well here's the thing
uh my why my why kept me going i didn't
want to
end up um like my parents and my parents
are great people i want to say that very
clearly
i think sometimes my words get kind of
uh misunderstood i have great parents
but my als
but also for my parents i learned i
don't want to live paycheck to paycheck
i don't want to struggle
um and so i quickly turned things
around i went gazelle intense
i took financial peace university i
started learning exactly what
stewardship meant
i started learning exactly what tithing
actually meant and how it benefited
me more than it benefited the actual
church i really started to understand
what money was and how it was a tool to
help me accomplish the things god has
put me on this earth to do and so
i say all that to say this you guys if
that sounds like you
to where you you thought about money
wrong um you're tired of being sick and
tired you're tired of living paycheck to
paycheck
you're tired of not accomplishing your
dreams then it's time for a new way of
thinking
because you have to believe you can get
rid of debt and you can can take
you can take control of your money
because here's the truth
you can we all can and it won't take
nearly as long as what you think so with
ramsey plus
we'll kick you off with 90 days of
guided help so you can put
more of your money back in your bank
account not in their bank account
in your bank account why work monday
through friday
why go through monday through friday
with labor so someone else can get the
fruit
of your labor no no no we're going to
stop that this year
because you're going to learn practical
ways to get small consistent wins
that add up to big results and better
habits and that means you'll get where
you want to go
faster debt free and spending your money
without worrying about a dime
this year you can make more progress
on your debt and saving than you ever
have i want you to get ramsey plus and
start living the life you want
faster to start ramsay plus for free i
want you to go to daveramsey.com right
now once you go to daveramsey.com
i want you to sign up with ramsey plus
you're going to get 90 days of guided
help you guys this is the thing that
that transformed
my life and i love
what we do because what we do is what i
personally do this has nothing to do
with dave ramsey
this is financial peace university
ramsey plus
changed my life right and because it
changed
my life i want to help others change
their life that's right and ramsay plus
is the way to go love it sorry to sound
so passionate about it you guys but
i mean this thing changed my life and my
kids will never know
what it feels like to struggle my kids
will never know what it feels like to
see their parents live in paycheck to
paycheck
my kids will go to disney world my kids
will be able to go to israel
i mean walter land where jesus walked
because their father and their mother
do not have debt they're going to be so
confused
why do you have debt to the world
because their parents don't have it
because of what i decided to do
back when i was 22 years old so check it
out you guys ramsay plus daveramsey.com
and ansley is with us in athens georgia
good afternoon ma'am how can um
dr d and i help hey dr d hey anthony hi
so my husband i'm sorry let me start we
are on baby step two
we have paid off a hundred and twelve
thousand dollars
less than a year we have gotten 112 we
moved down a car
and we've paid off we have a car left
and
some student loans and that's it very
cool cool so what's up how can we help
um so what i'm calling for is my husband
recently got awarded
a 100 va disability and with that
the kids go to college for free okay how
it works is they basically get a
1300 a month stipend and that can go
towards whatever
needs of college that it needs to go
towards so my question was
we don't want to open a 529 and have
that money set just for school
if they end up doing getting
scholarships and also having the va
money
so what what amount do we save for
college if any
and what is the best is it would it be
best to put it in a mutual fund or
or what's the best way to go about that
i mean i would still go ahead and put it
inside of
um a 529 because here's the thing
whatever school your son or daughter
goes to
you can actually withdraw so let's say
for an example school cost you ten
thousand dollars semester and they
actually have some scholarships well as
long as you have documentation from the
school you can withdraw
that ten thousand dollars now you can't
withdraw more than ten thousand
um but you can withdraw that without
paying any penalties on it because it is
you could technically say it's going
towards going towards the school
but i would still invest the money into
a 529
because that's going to be the best way
to grow and let's say for an example
they don't get all the scholarships and
uh the va and the gi bill
doesn't take care of all their school
now you have the means to go ahead and
provide for it
uh but i still think that the best
option right now for your kids
for your son's college is to go ahead
and put inside of 529
because there are some things that will
come in your benefit to actually pull
out
okay and what's what's a good amount if
if that is being planned
to take care of most of their college do
we still plan to put in the full amount
of time how does it sound real quick um
so we have two 12 year olds a three year
old and 18 month old
okay cool and so here's the thing right
now college right now is gonna cost you
about a hundred thousand dollars
um right now to go to school for a four
year degree plus room and board
so around their age bracket is going to
be right about maybe 115
and so i would just look at that math
and to see what do you have to do to get
there
to get to that 115 bracket for in-state
school
we don't do out-of-state unless we're
gonna pay cash to get a scholarship
so end statesmen cost you about 115 120
by the time they get to that age
so just look at the numbers and see what
you need to set aside to get there but
such a great question
dr d such a great hour with you james
madison thank you so much america this
is
the end of this hour this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have
a conversation about your life your
money
your relationships you name it we're
here to talk with you
my name is anthony o'neil host of the
popular youtube and podcast show the
table with anthony o'neil
and co-hosting with me today is national
best-selling author and host
of the dr john delony show the one and
only ramsey personality dr john deloney
and we're together taking your phone
calls today give us a call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five or you can hit us both up on
social media uh i am at anthony o'neil
dr john is at john delony john deloney i
was trying to get
over to your stuff we got we go complex
in this house
we really do we really really complex so
um if you have any questions you have
any concerns any comments um hit up dr
john at john delony you can hit me up on
instagram at
dot i mean doctor that's anthony o'neil
uh but right now we're taking your phone
calls triple eight eight two five
five two two five and renee is with us
in chicago
good afternoon renee how can dr john and
i help
hi guys um first of all thanks so much
for letting me be on your show
yeah um but i had a question regarding
just
student loans in general so um a little
background
i i'm starting a new job next week um
and i'm gonna make about sixty five
thousand dollars a year so
um not you know it's good a good first
start for my first job um outside of
school i just graduated from grad school
i'm 23 years old and i also have
about 42 000 dollars in federal student
loan debt
so i guess my question is about the best
plan and the best way
possible to pay this off as soon as
possible
um but also like if there's also a
chance to do that while also taking care
of myself like
you know still eating out like you know
every once in a while at a nice place or
like buying myself
like nice things every once in a while
you know
so i was just wondering if there's a way
to budget that
renee um yes no you don't have any
you don't have any time you don't have
any resources to be buying yourself nice
things okay
right now you're going to stay with the
college mindset you are broke
you did nice things to yourself for the
last six years okay
but i don't want to be broke hey listen
listen hey that's a problem
for 18 year old renee yes
listen 23 years paying the piper all
right renee
yeah so outside of these student loans
do you have any other debt
uh no i don't fortunately don't um
undergrad i didn't
have that luckily um and i actually
currently so i currently still live with
my parents okay
and i do plan on moving to
the city soon the city which i yeah
to chicago expensive yeah that's where
the job is
you can't you can't live outside of the
city and drive into the city
well my plan was to stay at home until i
have to go back to work because
you know because of covet everyone's
working from home now so
i'm not going to move now if i don't
have to but when
we do plan on going back then i do plan
on going
but the rent there is about 1200 1300
a month um so it's it's not
how old are you twenty-three
twenty-three what's your what's your
career what would you go to grad school
for
um so i'm doing uh like market research
and consulting
okay all right check this out yeah check
this out
oh sorry what was that i said check this
out okay you're not gonna like that
you got a pen and paper near you get a
pen and paper uh
yeah okay cool or just just yeah yeah
cause i'm about to give you some stuff
you need to do
okay here's number one
just write down no okay
no you you don't have time to buy
yourself nice things and
no you don't have time to be going on
nice vacations no you don't have
uh time to be going out with your
friends every other weekend no the
answer is no i want you to put that up
in your mirror every single day and look
at the word
no okay number two
is um
i think right now at 23 years old
staying home i'm okay with that
but at 23 also at the same time i want
you to have a solid plan
of how are you going to get outside of
your parents house i don't want you to
be there until you're 30. i don't want
you to stay there until you're 27.
um i'm gonna say give yourself at least
a good year at home
she's gotta move as soon as kova comes
as soon as you're as soon as you go back
to
to work in-house you gotta get out right
yeah you gotta go she said
she said that that's her yeah her
requirement i'll get you i'm just saying
if things prolong i'm saying she needs
to have an injection
you need to have an end date of when
you're going to leave um
and then here's the thing i'm not moving
to the city renae
i get it you're young you want to be
closer to the city get closer to your
job
but twelve hundred dollars a month right
now on rent when you can probably live
on the outskirts of the city
and drive something nice and living
something maybe around eight hundred
nine hundred dollars a month would be a
better option because right now
you need to attack this 42 000 student
loan debt and here's the thing
you're making great money so if you get
on a strict
budget if you can figure out how to get
your living expenses
very low i mean very low
you should be able to throw at least
25 000 uh towards this 42 000
this year you should be able to be out
of debt by
next year and i'm talking like you're
you're getting this job you're going to
be driving for uber
you're going to be trying to figure out
something you can do on the side to
generate another 20 000
because if you really get gazelle
intense renee you can honestly be
debt-free within the next
year 12 months 12 to 14 months you could
be debt free because right now you don't
have any expenses
so right now if you're staying at home
man i'm throwing everything towards debt
i'm gonna throw my mom and dead a couple
hundred dollars for food electricity
and water bills but outside of that man
i'm throwing everything at this 42
thousand dollars so that way
when you do leave your home you are debt
free
and you're still gonna live in the
outskirts because you need to set aside
that three to six months of expenses
and listen renee i promise anthony and i
get it
you went to grad school you're smart
you're fancy you're 23.
yeah you have oh man you're going to go
to the big city
and you're going to live it out exactly
but listen
you feel like you've arrived you feel
like you're 100 years old
you walk a little bit taller it's going
to be good what i'm telling you is this
on your 25th birthday if you are
debt-free
not if she will be yeah i like that you
will be debt-free on 25th birthday
you're going to realize that at the age
of 25
you aren't very old you're going to
realize that you have your entire life
ahead of you to do whatever
you want to do yes because 23 year old
renee sucked it up and got it done now
listen
you're looking at a guy right now who
with a young child
me and my wife moved into a dorm at a
college
so we wouldn't have expenses anthony
lived in his car
we have done some extreme things we've
done some crazy people
my friends our friends have been like
what are you doing you know what we're
doing we're changing everything because
this game
isn't going to play and i'll tell you
this at 25
you're not gonna remember those meals
you blew that money on at 23. you're not
gonna remember
that party on top of that party on top
of that party you're not i'm telling you
you're not gonna remember it
what you are gonna love doing is waking
up on your 25th birthday
having no payments and thinking i think
i was going to move to
yeah fill in the blank because you can
so renee hold on hold on the line i'ma
have madison give you a copy of destroy
your uh student loans
um it's a quick read that i read i want
you to stay online and get that and just
remember the caliber of your future will
be determined by the choices you
made today make the right one by
listening to dr john and i alright
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well st patrick's day brought some folks
a little luck this year
on wednesday the irs announced that it's
pushing the federal tax
deadline back i already did my taxes
and it's good all right everyone in the
u.s
now automatically gets an extra month to
file with the date moves from april 15th
to may 17th
amen that's for federal returns folks
not estimated quarterly payments or
state taxes
why did it get pushed back well the
pandemic's still affecting things when
you throw in the very recent tax changes
the april 15th deadline was looking like
a lot of trouble for a lot of people
with the change to may 17th you have an
extra month not just to file but to also
pay your tax bill
if you're in texas oklahoma louisiana
your tax date from the irs is still
june 15th because of the storms that hit
you so what does this all mean well it
means you have extra time to do your
taxes
but if you can file now especially if
you're due for a refund go ahead and do
it
that advice comes straight from the irs
and here's the thing
anthony i was a college professor for
years and whenever i would say all right
everybody
i know it's straight you're stressed i'm
gonna i'm gonna push this paper out
three more weeks
everybody just waited two and a half
more weeks to get that you know what i
mean they just move their stress down
if you can file file get it done right
now yeah
if you need help filing either online or
the trusted tax advisor
we can help text tax to 33789
and get it done that's tax 33789
i used the ramsey tax software this year
i for my house
did you it was simple it was awesome it
was quick
i did it at my kitchen table it was
nothing it was your wife
yeah it was simple man it's awesome i
love it i love it man i love it
well jesse is with us in arizona good
afternoon how can
dr d and i help all right gentlemen how
you guys doing today doing well man how
can we help
all right uh this uh this question is
more uh
for dr john baloney in a relationship
aspect
i love it um currently um let me just
start out by
saying i'm madly in love with this woman
i was doing something
i wouldn't do jesse any time somebody
jesse anytime somebody starts out with
that sentence i know
we're gonna have some trouble this is
gonna be interesting no no no well
maybe a little bit but cause she is
probably listening to this
um so the problem we're having right now
is she comes home every day from her job
her job
and she's unhappy she's crying she calls
me you know two three times a day
because
we just talk to each other a lot
throughout the day and and it's always
complaints about her job she wants to
get out and she hates it
she hates her job i don't like the word
hate but she hates her job
okay um she has a cosmetology
she is a certified cosmetologist and
that is her passion
and she loves it okay but the problem
we're running into
is she doesn't want to just work at some
you know
average place where she's a
cosmetologist she wants to
do hair she wants to be in her own
studio and make good money
well right now she's in a secure job
where it gives her a secure paycheck
um our incomes differ
by about double so i make about double
what she does okay
i told her i have your back yep
no matter what i just want to get you
out of this job
and get you into your career now we've
we've been on and off for about 20 years
so this isn't a new relationship no
we're not married we're gonna get
married okay but
we need our relationship more secure in
order to do that i need her to be
secure at her job at her career
so i want to get her out of the
insurance what she's doing right now
because she does like uh write checks
and stuff for a big insurance company
and i want her to get her into
cosmetology her being happy
and we've we've thought of other plans
on how to do it but
she she doesn't really she doesn't
really trust me
per se um when it comes to having her
back she's always been a single mom
with two boys she's always been the
provider the
alpha male of the house now i step in
you know
and and yeah i know the kids and i know
her but
she's still used to being the major
breadwinner the person who
always has to be there for the boys yeah
and i get it she's a mom like
i wouldn't want her to be any other way
like your kids first
but how do i get her to trust me
to to allow me to take over some of the
finances in the house
so she can pursue her career and get out
of this job
man um you're not going to like my
answers
how direct you are how direct do you
want me to be
you know what hey i'm on dave's show i'm
going to be real direct i'm going to
take
from old man here here's the thing
number one if you've known her
for 20 years and she doesn't trust you
there's a reason yep number two
you can't make her do anything yup and
the fact that you're trying to make her
do something
is only making her not trust you more
well
okay this is the thing doctor is she
this is something that she wants to do
as well hey honey hey jesse jesse
jesse yeah she's raised two boys
yeah she can do anything
oh i know she can say she wants to
change but she doesn't
because if she did she would okay yeah
and so what you have to do is
be in love with the person she is not
the person you think you can mold and
create for her
yeah no i'm totally in love with her the
way she is i like
i wouldn't want her any other way hey
but no matter what
but listen brother what you told me is
when
she can finally deal with this relation
i mean with her job stuff
then finally then finally i can marry
her
and what you're telling her is when you
become the person
that i want you to be then you'll be
good enough for me
not till then and so you've got your
relationship
though absolutely wrote down
on my paper while you were talking your
relationship math is off
if you worked for amazon they'd fire you
because you cannot make an algorithm
your a plus b good thing i don't work
out that's wrong
hey listen you are you
have walked into a situation where you
want to be the savior of it
i love your heart man i see what you see
somebody that you care about
i just want to support her that's right
i don't want to give her
i don't want to give her all things i
don't want to give her choices i want
her to make those choices
i just want her to trust me that i'll
have her back
that's right so when it comes to like an
electric bill comes in and
and she needs you know she doesn't have
it sam dave i can pay just ask me and
i'll pay
that's right listen listen listen it's
it's
your heart is good okay your heart is
good here yeah you've got to sit down
with her
not about not about what your job's
going to be give me a solution not about
hey i've got your back financially
but you guys have 20 years of stuff
y'all got to work through
there's a reason she doesn't trust you
to pick up a i trust anthony i met
anthony a year ago
and i trust him that if i needed if i
called him said hey bro i'm about to cut
my lights off
you know what i mean so there's
something there a 20-year arc of your
relationship that there's no trust there
the second thing is you got to decide am
i going to marry this person for who she
is
even if she's in a tough job or
am i going to be out because the way
you've written this out for yourself
you've provided yourself with a wife
when she does what you want her to do
and i know that's not your heart so i
didn't feel like that's what you've done
but it is
and if she's listening to this rewind it
and say are those guys crazy
and she'll probably get a tear in her
eye and say no
and then maybe that's gonna be the
avenue for a hard conversation anthony i
can feel you next to
me pulsing man i'll probably get in
trouble like i did yesterday so i think
i should just go for it not say what i
really want to say say what you're going
to say man
because say what you're going to say
again i'm going to say
let me set this up like this this is not
dave ramsey's opinion this
is not dr john delony's opinion this is
anthony o'neill's opinion i'm scooting
over in case you get struck by lightning
if my friend came home to me and said
i'm still dating this guy after 20 years
i'm telling her to leave
hmm that's just bottom line i'm just i'm
i'm not dealing with someone
no by the way that's my opinion too yeah
that's your opinion thank you yes
give me some love yeah because i felt i
felt like 20 years
there's a reason why she doesn't trust
you and it's not just all on her there's
something inside of you
the man that is not allowing her to open
up now again i'm not a relationship
expert this is your lane i'm just saying
if my cousin if my sister if my
friend came to me i'm saying baby girl
move on i mean
if a man don't have your heart after a
year two years that ain't the one
well if if it's about
achievement right it's about when you do
these things then i'm gonna be able to
love you
and that's a hard recipe after 20 years
i was about to say something else but
you know what this is the ramsay show
and we'll be right back after this break
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show my name
is anthony o'neill ramsey personality
and joining me in the studio today is
ramsey personality national best-selling
author
dr john deloney and together we're
taking your phone calls we have this
segment and one more segment after this
so give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five again the number
here is triple eight eight two five
five two two five and sean is with us in
phoenix arizona good afternoon sean how
can a dr d and i hope
hi guys thank you very much for taking
the call yeah
um so i just graduated from college and
i'm debt free
and uh i on top of a great job i just
found out i'm going to be getting
a 15 000 gift okay um
besides that i'm also engaged and my
fiance owes about twenty thousand
dollars so my question is
should i invest the fifteen thousand or
should i just give it all to her
what's the gift from man yeah um my uh
uh my parents are downsizing selling
their house and they're uh
they're calling it pre-inheritance they
their their goal is to spend everything
they have so they said
we'll give you fifteen thousand dollars
now and maybe that can help you out
cool very cool how much money do you
have in your savings right now sean
so i have about three thousand dollars
in my savings and then a six thousand
dollars in my 401k
okay cool um when you get married
uh next year next year okay next year
okay all right sounds good september
2022
okay all right sounds good sounds good
uh i'm going to say you take that
fifteen thousand dollars and you max out
your your
your three to six months of expenses um
that's gonna be the first step since you
are 100 debt free
um and then what's that from there i'm
gonna say do not give that money to your
fiance right now
i'm gonna say put that into a savings
account use that towards your wedding
and if you uh get married and let's say
you have more money
you can cash flow your wedding and then
once you all get married
check this out you're not giving her the
15k you're not giving her money
uh now you two are in debt you're paying
off
your debt together together right okay
so
just because you come into the marriage
without any debt the moment you join
forces and you become
one you are now back in debt so then yes
i would take that check and write off
and pay off
uh the debt that you two now have
together
but for right now i'm gonna put um all
that into the savings account
you're not gonna touch three months of
that um then you put the rest of it into
another savings account to save towards
your marriage
save towards your wedding um and then
whatever you have left over after that
i would definitely say bae on honeymoon
night um you know hey
let's go ahead and start attacking uh
your your loans your debt
and i have some money um and i want to
put it all towards uh
that because we're in debt together
makes sense john
yeah so so that's it's better to wait
until after we're married to start
helping her out with the loan
absolutely absolutely because i know you
love her but what what happens let's
just say worst case scenario
yeah y'all wait wake up one day and she
says i don't love you no more yeah
you know now you gave her all this money
and you screwed now i'm not saying it
will happen
but it happens a lot but it does happen
yeah yeah
fair enough don't don't combine your
debts yet and um until y'all
are in this for the long haul yeah man
thank you so much for calling in man
we're praying for you
rooting for you i believe you're going
to be married i mean i just believe that
you know she
she's you i could tell you love it
because you're talking about spending
your money anytime a man talks about
spending his money on another woman he
loves her he loved her a lot because uh
i'm about to say something else again i
keep remembering this is the ramsay show
not the table with anthony
katie is in jackson good afternoon katie
um how can dr d and i help
yes i have a question about their homes
my husband and i started our babysit
journey in july
2019 and we are finally on our last
set which is my um 52 000
in student loans we have not paid on
them in over five years
and we were wondering if we could offer
a settlement a lump sum or should we
just start doing the monthly payments
uh no uh are they in collections
um yeah are they in collections are they
just deferred
um they are not deferred anymore they
are in [ __ ] so these are these are
private loans
um no they're federal okay cool uh i
mean i would call them and see if they
will more than likely they won't accept
it
um but i would definitely give them a
call and just offer them something how
much can you put towards them right
now if you could because you know
settlement is pretty much one lump sum
yes right now we have just under 20
000 and that's not including our
emergency fund
yeah uh i would just start making
payments i would call them and just uh
immediately go ahead and put that twenty
thousand dollars down on it right now
and just start making payments towards
uh the rest
um you say you've been doing it the baby
steps since 2019
right okay so you weren't making minimum
payments since 2019
yeah okay all right how come you just
stopped paying on them
well actually i never really started i
was in school and then i went back to
school so they've been deferred and
deferred
um and then we just never started paying
off we were within paycheck to paycheck
and not really making the best decisions
when we were younger um but then we woke
up and had our wine
and in july 2019 decided to start paying
off all the debt we paid off a little
over 70 000 so far
hey that's amazing what's your household
income right now
right now it's 120. we started around 85
and we've updated this
awesome how many kids do you have five
five two cool katie
so here's the thing you got five you got
a lot of mouths to feed you
you put that 20 grand towards them today
then immediately goes down to what
42 thousand right and making what you
make
you guys can hustle and hustle and
hustle it's gonna be a grindy year and
nobody wants another grind a year after
the
the last growing year especially with
five kids but go just get it done
yeah yeah katie are y'all on the budget
katie
oh yeah we are we need to know that
we'll be done by august
okay so it says you'll be done by august
of this year or next year
this year oh awesome very
yeah absolutely that's good i like that
katie yeah
congratulations i love it so yeah just
go ahead and put that twenty thousand
dollars towards it give them a call and
ask them if they if they will settle
um it depends on i don't know i mean
private loans i know that you can get
them to settle um
some agencies depending on your
financial situations will allow you to
settle but more than likely they will
not
um because you know you can't even file
bankruptcy
on student loans and so it's just very
tricky on those
uh but give them a call and say hey can
we work out something we got twenty
thousand dollars as a lump sum we can
give towards it right now can we knock
this down
get some interest not down maybe uh but
more than likely they won't
if not just hey just attack that other
42 thousand dollars become debt free
so that way you and your family can can
move forward all right katie
um sale on the line i appreciate it no
problem stay on the line i'm gonna have
uh madison give you a copy of my destroy
your student loan debt
um so quick read it's about 80 pages
long take you about a good hour and a
half to listen to it
um i i wrote this last year dr d because
when i wrote the book um a debt free
degree
and i was out there on book tour and
we've sowed thousands of copies of this
book
um and while i was out there on book
tour every parent
every parent and i mean i'm probably
over exaggerating a little bit but i'll
say
nine out of ten parents came up to him
said hey
what do i do i have student loans how do
i pay off my student loans and i'm like
man
and so i wrote this quick read um called
destroy your student loan debt the
step-by-step plan on how to get rid of
your student loan debt quickly
um and it's 80 pages long american i
really want you to get this book and
here's why
uh because when we really do the
research and study
what's preventing us from reaching our
financial goals what's preventing us
from building true wealth
one of the top three things was our
student loans uh young people are
graduating college going back home
thinking that they pay off their
students within three years with study
shows
that it takes them 12 years to pay off
their student loans
and if we really go deeper minority
people of color
it takes them anywhere from 20 to 23
years to pay off their support
and so for me i was like man i got to
write a book that can really really
help people get out of this student loan
crap
and i mean that you know because this is
preventing people from building wealth
from buying
homes from starting businesses uh so i
really want y'all to go to
daveramsey.com for
store get the book or go to my website
anthonyniel.com get the book to show
your student loans it's 10 bucks
and hey this last uh last caller makes a
great salary was
on the plan yes and people just like to
act like student loans aren't real
yes people they are real pay them back
they're a debt
do what you said you were going to do
and get them out of the way hey
just 10 bucks can change your life
expect well if i'm polite is
this ten dollars can change the next ten
years of your life go to daveramsey.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
scripture in quote today comes from
psalms chapter 33 verses 4
for the word of the lord is right and
true he is faithful
in all he does jack canfield said
for every reason it's not possible there
are hundreds of people who have faced
the same circumstances
and succeeded how often
do we feel all by ourselves like we're
the only one dealing with distress
this grief this pain this relationship
issue wow
everybody does right i'm right there
with you brother
man good quote ben is with us and uh the
beautiful sydney australia good
afternoon ben how can we help man such
an honor to talk to you as well
great thank you thank you for having me
on the show and good morning from
sydney uh my question today
is do i
buy a small unit which would be a down
size for our family of two kids
in an inflated market or do i
move in with my in-laws in a massive
house
and save a bit of money uh what's your
goals here man yeah what are we trying
to do
um well i would love to buy a place um
you know we've been married almost 10
years and we have never bought a place
we're 100
debt free now at the moment uh the
kind of things that are a bit difficult
for us is
i still haven't secured a job since
corona i lost my job
due to corona but my wife has a
successful business
she's on maternity leave at the moment
and i'm actually looking
after the business for her um unpaid
so it gets a little bit trickier but the
inflated market in sydney is
pretty similar to what i'd imagine is
happening in los angeles at the moment
where
everyone's leaving moving out a little
bit further
and people are moving into the area
where i live so
the rental and the sales are going up 20
30
so we're just a little bit unsure what
the right step would be either for the
next three to six months or
a bit long term do you have a lease
coming up why why do you have to move
right now
yeah yeah unfortunately we do we uh
the owner sold and the new owners want
to move in and
it was such a dream house we're near the
stage
well below market rent um you know
bigger than what we needed but yeah now
it's uh the equivalent would be
paying now a one-bedroom apartment for
the price we're paying for this house
wow wow well here's my thing you're
saying
if you went home it would only be for
about three to six months correct
yeah that's what i'm assuming just that
the market might
chill out a bit okay okay cool do you
have a good relationship with your
in-laws
yes i do yeah um you know i'm not a huge
fan of going home
i'll be honest but in this situation
with the pandemic
it sounds like you are really thinking
this through um it sounds like you're
going into this with a plan
uh with their strategic plan now this is
not gonna be for a long term
uh this is just so me and my wife my
family and i we can get back on our feet
and you're gonna continue looking for
work um i say ben go there because the
last thing i want to do is see you go
out there and spin
over market um and just you got no job
yeah
i don't want you to do that on maternity
leave yeah yeah so so go go in there
with your in-laws but then really
um over dinner sit down with your
in-laws um
as the you know the man of your home say
hey listen here's my plan here's a plan
for
our family our goals be here for for no
more than six months
i'm going to be doing this every single
day every single week to every single
week
to to secure a job um and just
hold yourself accountable and keep
updating them you know
keep letting them know like hey this is
what i'm doing i went out here hopefully
we hear back soon or we didn't hear back
because i think sometimes parents and
in-laws just want to feel as if
okay they're trying to do something so
just show them hey i'm i'm going to be a
provider
i'm going to take care of your daughter
uh this is what i'm doing this is only
temporarily until we can get back on our
feet
and thank you so much and so that that's
what i would do i would go ahead and
take that six months back in with
my in-laws yeah and yeah this only makes
sense
if you've got a great relationship with
them
um and like anthony said you guys set up
really firm boundaries on the front end
i think you should i think you should
pay rent i think you should contribute
around the house
i think you should put something in
writing with your father-in-law he may
tell you
you ain't doing that in my house which
is fine but the
the more you can get everybody on the
same page going forward then in month
three or month four
someone's gonna say something or
someone's gonna leave towels out or
they're gonna forget how loud grandkids
are
and they're gonna start him hauling
around when it's time for you guys to go
um and so yeah make it as clear as
possible but i'm with anthony i think
this is the right move for you
don't buy a house without a job man yeah
don't do it don't do it good market bad
market don't buy a house at a job don't
do it
rachel's with us in new york good
afternoon rachel how can we help
uh hi thank you for taking my call
um i just was wondering um well i'm
currently in baby step two paying off my
debt snowball
um and i was wondering when you pay off
um
credit cards if there's a better way to
do it
that won't affect your credit score like
when i
should i wait till all of them are paid
off and cancel them or should i
cancel one at a time as i pay them off
counsel them all right now
cut them up don't wait until you pay it
off because here's the problem rachel
um if you wait i guarantee you you're
going to swipe it again you're going to
use it again
if you cancel it if you turn it off if
you cut it up if you get it out of your
system
um you you won't do it right now now
here's the truth you may go apply for
another one
um you know but you have to have
discipline and right now you got you
have to be uncomfortable
and the discipline part is huge because
discipline for me is to bridge
from where you are where we are today to
where we want to go tomorrow
and if you're on if you're following our
plan okay this
what i'm hearing from you is and what
i'm thinking you're saying is i want to
be debt free and i want to have
financial peace
and so to have that you have to be
uncomfortable and you got to have
discipline and the uncomfortable part is
cut up the credit cards
and i guarantee you right um in a few
years you'll thank yourself and so don't
worry about the credit score
okay i get it well i need to go rent a
car
or um i may have to you know not may but
eventually one day i want to get a house
um if you follow our plan if you follow
our process we will show you how to do
all of this
without a credit score we will show you
how to do it
um and still win in the process okay so
i wouldn't wait
yeah i wouldn't wait go ahead and cut it
up okay
thank you hey no problem thanks for
calling in uh
brayden is with us in marshall good
afternoon braden how can we help
hey guys how are you doing doing good
man your last call of the day talk to us
what's on your heart
um i am a freshman in college in my
second semester okay um i am also a
student athlete okay
and that comes into play out later i
just sat down with my academic advisor
today
and it looks like i could possibly
graduate
um a year early okay but i have to play
my cards right because
small school and all the classes are
only offered in
certain times of the year or whatever
sure um so
do you think i forgot to mention i also
go to the seventh cheapest four-year
school in the nation
um so i don't think i should have
without any debts
my whole time there and if i do it'll
just be small so i'm just wondering if
my cards don't play out right as far as
um saying they're only three years would
it be
worth it to try and get another miner
i'm going for egg solutions i have a i'm
getting a minor in egg business and i'm
thinking of possibly getting another
miner
that doesn't play out right in agronomy
um
so i i can't speak to the the market
viability of the extra credentialing or
the extra stuff you're going to learn in
those
other in those other fields right so i
don't know how that translates
what i can tell you is yes a minor can
be good
a minor can be help you with your
marketability it can teach you some
stuff that's going to round out your
major degree
but i'm going to always push back to
weigh the cost do you have the cash if
you can do it if you can keep an extra
year of eligibility then go for it but
also
and we don't talk about this a lot
anthony what was
what is going to be your lost year of
working full-time too
because that's also a cost so let's say
you can get in there for free but you're
going to cost you 50
dollars in lost income you may want to
consider that if you can get out of
there in three years
man i got now nothing else to say to
that thank you dr
john for joining me today man amazing
show i want to thank our producer james
child and our uh
sitting in for our assistant producer
madison she
did a great job in america thank you for
listening to
us too it's been amazing day this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
you